[Music]
you look extraordinary you did that for
me you look absolutely gorgeous but you
are yeah that's a tight tight dress you
know it makes me have to work out yeah
well let's talk about that you are in
incredible shape what are we talking
about here you know I was doing yoga
yoga okay but I don't now because I hurt
my back you hurt your back I hurt my
back so now I Teeter Tina I don't I I
have I have some issues in my low left
side of the back lower back yeah that's
where my problem is and so now I started
Pilates Pilates I've done some Pilates
about that II the key do you have that
guys sure sure
the key for the back problems is it's in
yoga it's called mula bandha
and what it is is when you exercise or
when you do anything you should be
Keighley or kegeling the kegel exercise
i don't it's the cake the king of
exercise I I'm thinking of for your
vagina no it's not vagina there's a
little muscle he's got terrible body
advice
you know what I'm lying it is for your
vagina because what I've heard of
kegeling keaghlan when I've heard of it
I've heard of like women doing it
exclusively but you should be doing it
for your back I don't know what it what
it is when I heard it was for women I
got all scared in this erectile
dysfunction as well Oh
ket years and years so if they're if
we're one to have erectile dysfunction
and this guy not a problem but if one
were to have that problem it would it
would help there is a well it would help
me but for your back which is what we're
concentrating on you I think let's get
back to the penis well I don't even know
what it is what is it how do I do it
there is a muscle in your glue not the
big muscle that everyone thinks I have
no muscles back there what's good
because you either are overextended or
kind of like you know inverted or
whatever it's called if you're if you're
flattered I have yeah I go pretty much I
mean I don't want to be rude or anything
you can see there's nothing going this
is not there's nothing here it's just a
straight drop straight drop from the
shoulders right to the back of the heel
you could drop a penny back there it
just goes right down no interference
clear drop well for a clear drop what
you're gonna do is like you would take
this okay see this pick what that ring
payment the ring and I just terrified me
this little thing I'm doing you see that
little clinch yeah hold it and do it
there do it down here imagine with my
with my bottom with your body no not on
bottom imagine you were you were peeing
and you stopped it midstream
look like you're doing it I'm doing
this is how I usually look
this is me in a moment of ecstasy and
watching a child's balloon pop I mean
this is every ocean I have I'm doing it
right now
my back feels okay and if you do that
you should do that 70 percent of the day
I can't barely do this I can barely do
this for another few seconds killing me
know if you do finally bleeding right
now blood is just filling my pants that
sentence has ever been uttered on this
first time for everything god okay so
that helps you I'm gonna track you that
helps everyone it's great for your lower
back
honestly I'm doing it okay you're doing
it right now as we speak
yeah that's why I'm just making it on
the walk out here well I saw that yeah
haha